rodar é bom é show uma exata contar uma
história que aconteceu comigo quando era
criança
é quando uma escola pública
e nessa escola havia uma casa onde
morava uma pessoa morar uma uma pessoa
com o filho
mais ou menos como acontece hoje o
caseiro em um sítio com o zelador clube
sabia que morava na casa ele tinha um
problema das crianças além de via é o da
casa abriu a primeira vez não conseguia
se movimentar bem e make rastejava pelo
chão
apesar de ser assim mais velha do que eu
não conseguia falar bem de articular bem
as palavras e ele gritava pela mãe e eu
me lembro que eu tive uma aula aconteceu
eu tive uma sensação daquele momento que
foi bastante previsível uma criança que
tivesse se deparando com aquela situação
na primeira vez na vida me assustei me
assustei eu tenho medo dele
só que apesar de ser criança aquela
sensação que eu tive
mikhail tempo sabia que aquilo não era
uma coisa é certa se sentindo uma coisa
boa porque até hoje 40 anos depois a
mesma história público mas esse encontro
desse sentimento que eu tive
por outro lado foi bom porque ele fez
refletir ó porque eu sentia aquilo né
é a resposta é simples porque aquela
época as pessoas que tinham algum tipo
de digamos diferença praticamente em
causa nada não saiam às ruas
eu quase escondidos às vezes
as famílias existe um preconceito muito
forte saiu com roupas quando saíram as
pessoas ficavam olhando e comentando e
fazer com que elas ficassem mais tempo
de casa na quinta e o que transformava
num ciclo vicioso evoluindo e passaram a
receber determinadas a agentes que elas
crianças funcional e eficiente é
especial pessoal necessidade especial
portador de deficiência pessoa com
deficiência
enfim uma pessoa um grupo de pessoas que
na verdade se afastavam um padrão médias
atípica tá população a estatística que
realmente essas pessoas sobre o momento
infelizmente a nossa sociedade passou a
incluir as leis incluíram as forças e
obrigatória e as pessoas de casa o que é
o óbvio né acontecido antes naquele
momento a gente conseguir presenciais e
aí o que acontecia no mundo que não tava
muito organizado para para recebermos né
e então as pessoas começavam a tentar
criar é é a possibilidade para receber
essas pessoas
o exemplo clássico disso é que a gente
pode começar no brasil porém é essa
dessa forma era mais uma adaptação
existia para alguém que tinha um tipo de
deficiência do dia exatamente ao que foi
criado para essa pessoa
mesmo que essa pessoa teria então
costumo às vezes brincar eu falo assim ó
cara bota uma tábua imagens cada chamas
de rampa de cadeirante e de
acessibilidade no meio é eu já tive
oportunidade de se ver o rampas com um
estilo gatinha não cometam imprimir que
nem com uma cadeira motorizada uma
pessoa com deficiência com o tricolor ia
conseguir subir ou mesmo às vezes é
amigo keké cadeirantes vai levar é
pesado na rampa e sozinho conseguirá
assim você tem essa possibilidade mas
não tem a pessoa não tem a autonomia e
de vilson que além de pesquisar as
pessoas são grandes amigos e com vilson
é que é orientador avisam quando era
criança
então essas questões assim a idade dele
e ela é bastante do tempo entretanto
pensar o que a gente pode fazer para
modificar e melhorar um pouco a vida
dele né e das pessoas que têm algum
deste pessoal e então assim a gente
estuda bastante a parte de
acessibilidade pra as pessoas que têm
algum déficit visual para trabalhar no
computador e bom mas estamos
necessitando de artes é pra música no
computador e em especial ao meu trabalho
é a parte escrita e tal e computadores
então quando a pessoa que não enxerga
vai tentar trabalhar no computador
o primeiro o primeiro ferramenta ela vai
aprender a lidar
é como se chama de leitores de tela são
os screenagers é um tipo de software que
é capaz de transformar o texto em fala
só transformar o texto em fala nem
sempre é o que soluciona as coisas por
exemplo se a gente tiver uma imagem
o leitor de tela tem o que falar nesse
trecho de mata
se a gente tiver o texto esse texto
estiver tendo como imagem
léo tocou consegue ler se destacar
dentro de uma imagem
na nossa área em busca de tudo o que
você imaginar uma partitura praticamente
um gráfico são simples com desenhos são
imagens
o leitor de tela em pouca influência e
isso ajuda muito corpo e se desse tipo
de trabalho
além do que a gente tem que parar pra
pensar assim olha se eu não conseguir
enxergar por que comprar um livro que
tem o monitor uma coisa assim tão bem
essa questão que estou dizendo que essa
cidade é feita a adaptação esse monitor
foi criado um cara que recebe o chef aí
você vem com o software pra tentar fazer
uma ação para que essa pessoa que
enxerga possam utilizar esse recurso mas
porque esse monitor então é necessário e
hilton e monitor lá no computador dele o
tempo inteiro com uma janelinha
clique aqui para ser o que é e aí como é
que o cara que enxerga vai pegar mal se
vai posicionar o ponteiro um ponto na
tela vai dar um ou dois cliques
então o que eles têm pensado é como a
gente pode criar alternativas que sejam
pensadas desde a origem pra uma pessoa
que tenha um determinado tipo de
deficiência
no nosso caso de pesquisa muito sobre
essa coisa da deficiência visual
eu estou tentando desenvolver um
software onde a escrita da partitura é
feita através deste texto porque o dela
eles conseguem interpretar um texto
muito bom texto
a pessoa a uma tinha nenhum assim em
breve no meio de um grupo de cinco
linhas posicionar aquilo a gente está
tentando criar uma coisa assim
relató colcheia e no momento que aqui ou
processado a gente vai ter como aimar ou
a gente vai ter com um som ea gente
conseguir criar alguma coisa que desde o
princípio já esteja sendo criar em cima
desse tipo de objetivo é que já existe
coisa boa também o computador usa
bastante o teclado e um teclado ele é
feito pra escrever texto porém a pessoa
que não enxerga nela poder ler texto ela
utiliza se do brian instituição vai
ficar uma coisa pra gente e cobraria um
sistema onde você tem pontos em relevo
que a pessoa pode passar num e quando se
sente pelo ta certo muito alto ou baixo
são seis pontos torno de duas colunas
três pontos em cada uma ea pessoa quando
passa um sente quase naqueles pontos
também de ronaldo e conseguem
interpretar aquilo como um sim uma letra
agora imagina quando esse cara vai
escrever no teclado como é que vai
localizar no teclado uma coisa que no
dia a dia para ele é feito em praia
decorre há tempo para quem fez curso de
fotografia com as letras e símbolos do
teclado quem detecta o objetivo da chave
o acesso à cultura centrada e segunda do
computador o outro
além de cuidar do teclado do outro é de
uma pessoa que não pode enxergar o que é
escrito teclado
algumas dessas você tem combinação a
mesma tecla tem 23 quase - qualquer
pessoa vai conseguir gravar com aquilo
nesse nesse sentido de tentar criar uma
interface de entrada de dados ou seja um
dispositivo onde a pessoa que tem um
déficit visual possa colocar os dados no
computador mais próximo
a gente tem que trabalhar com esse
dispositivo que a gente batizou de 80
novas elas têm três pontos em cada mão
em que com os quais é a pessoa que tem
um visual pode ter uma selva praia na
mão e vai escrever
já a praia e que é a linguagem com a
qual ele vai utilizar no dia a dia a
gente tem se debatido também como uma
com a questão
a nossa amiga magali disse sobre 66
bons de acessibilidade mas tem o outro é
a cidade financeira levaram o
equipamento que que ele é acessível e
que foi originalmente criado para que a
civilidade
às vezes não é acessível financeiramente
então também não adiantou muito a
senhora existe aquilo mas nós com braços
podem comprar a gente trabalhar num
lugar não tentar tal macinho nessa
história da acessibilidade pensado assim
a partir da origem é e pensamos em fazer
a adaptação quanto mais será que a gente
vai conseguir fazer sem adaptação criar
coisas originais e que estejam realmente
disponíveis as pessoas